hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bunker 16 an indie horror
game that I actually vetted and is
actually highly reviewed so let's get
into it
well I mean not like the past games that
I played haven't been that all whoa
excuse me why is there a separate
mechanic to open the handle oh oh okay
well how complicated if you want me to
make this for me how complicated
nevermind I can't talk today either way
I figured that I'm gonna be wandering
around for a while so let's get nice and
comfortable in this eerie and destitute
environment can I hear a grown e grown
someone can't be jumping out at me this
early okay toilets good Oh
oh that's a shower my oh I get it okay
that's for couples who can't stand away
from each other and they want to hold
hands while one dumping and one takes a
shower isn't that adorable isn't that
adorable
love is beautiful oh okay moving on so
the story of this game is that this dude
was running away from the storm and
wanted to take shelter in some place and
diary of George Walker I fled a storm
and took shelter in this abandoned
bunker it sounds oddly familiar as soon
as I was inside the door close by me now
I can't open it the door must have
locked automatically when it closed that
there's a keyhole on the door but of
course no key are you me or is that some
other guy who got trapped in here like a
poor sap probably another guy but
actually whoa hey don't be jumping me up
on stuffing things I don't much care for
it what what what what is that just
might does my flashlight have a strobe
function is that really what I have
there why why would I have that and that
sounds creepy and crawly and creaky
creepy spooky skeletons gonna come
jumping out at me oh boy oh no damn I am
supposed to attend it sorry I can't talk
I am supposed to attend a conf call at
10:00 p.m. I need to find a way out of
here let's hope there's an emergency
exit or a window that is large enough
huge thank you to whoever invented the
flashlight and batteries let's hope this
place is not too
well I got some bad news about that well
I can actually open the dress oh I can
open everything that's kind of awesome
by itself that's little details that I
haven't seen before
oh oh I got it so I got to go find the
fuses looks like one's already in there
oh ah so I have one fuels I didn't know
if I grabbed the fuse already so that's
gonna turn on the thing so that I can
get out of here but the coffee cups the
fuses where are the fuse is that yeah
but I hear a grumbly gross okay can i
man what you doing there what you're
doing on down there don't be messing
with my light cuz I got a strobe
function
that'll moderately disturb you if not
dissuade you completely from eating my
bones I can't have that now I don't need
it I'm too much of a badass to need a
medkit alrighty then anybody home
has anybody seen George Walker yeah my
George Walker cuz I have no idea at the
moment more medkit things but I can't
felt like there's a lot of stuff to open
but I can't seem to get anything out of
them there's no emergency exit and there
are no windows that would have been far
too easy wouldn't it I will have to
start searching for the key to unlock
the main door well I don't know about no
windows this little gun hole if you
weren't so inflexible you could probably
squeeze your way through there okay
there's a lot of detail put into this
it's a creepy crawly very very cramped
bunker imagine if this was an oculus
rift port I would get very
claustrophobic in this because I
actually do get Clutton oh that's just a
buzzy buzzing I thought that was a groan
a spooky creepy skate case is there
actually gonna be something in here
because I don't know what I'm looking
for
I've now searched for an hour too but I
haven't been able to find the key yet I
had a wrench I could maybe remove the
screws on the main door of course I do
not have a wrench with me what who takes
a wrench on a hike right what do you
mean you were taking a hike why would
anyone be so scared of the rain that
they were just going to bunker I guess
if the preference and you didn't know
that you were about to be myrtle eyes by
a giant monster but I mean still what is
the point
I have no watch but I assume that it's
almost midnight I have missed the conf
call damn I am dead tired I saw a couple
beds in one of the rooms I'll take a nap
there and continue searching for the key
once I wake up I am glad that there have
been a few more of these actually what
is this and what does that say on that
Oh bandages I am glad that there are a
few more of these actual quality horror
games oh I just made a circle well oh
don't tell me I got a oh I got to open
every single ding dong damn box and
barrel and thing looking for a fools I
don't even know where to find a Fu's I
don't even know if I'll pick it up
automatically if you're gonna stash it
in my face
please go stash it in my face so I need
to go back to the kitchen write down
exactly where these things are or not
the kitchen or wherever that the fuse
box was in the kitchen I don't think it
was in the kitchen I knew the way I need
to go back then I see something
bye ru [ __ ] step out into the light if
you want to face me
come on gigantic brain anybody no didn't
think so
okay no I was the kitchen okay so okay
so there was a kitchen in here then
there's an office bedroom a manís I was
in the office I was just in there how do
i oh I'm not supposed to get the fuse
okay I'm an idiot I'm not supposed to
get the fuses this is just where I put
the fuses in ah so if it's in the
kitchen mess that means it'll actually
work right boom baby
what did that do for me why did I do
that I'm gonna cook me up some gumbo
so I don't have enough fuses but I need
to go somewhere else so let's try the
office cuz it was just around the corner
right okay was that just the ventilation
system or is there something actually
after me somebody want to say something
okay so this is the office right oh
there we go but uh what was the point of
that what's the point what was the point
of this what is the point I need to find
a key but this doesn't seem to be
anything actually here I don't know I'll
keep trying it back and forth if there's
too much it's wandering about I'm gonna
just you know skip to the later okay I'm
gonna go find the bedroom cuz I'm so
tired and confusing napping one of their
electric vibrating beds I sure hope they
had this in the Nazi times when they
built this bunker or something like why
would a bunker just be in the middle of
woods can't be in America those aren't
out there I don't think they're right
now did I go this way yeah I did cuz I
was a claustrophobic area so where was
the bedroom where was the gosh
oh this was the bedroom do ya well I'm
waiting for a monster oh oh why am I
taking a nap oh that was me
no that couldn't have been me why did I
need the lights on to take a nap that
seemed like counterintuitive
Oh Sammy that better be me
that better be me storing I just gotta
say that right now suck balls
no no Dave
then
no no wait a minute okay I'm really
confused
am i George Walker yeah okay when I woke
I heard noises coming from outside my
room I hoped that maybe someone had
opened the main bore bore and entered
the bunker as soon as I went outside my
room the noise were gone the maid door
is still closed and there's no one
around so that is me I'm finding my own
notes I think and time is going very
strangely here sorry I apologize for
nothing you are a douche so are you in
the shower of the bathroom cause that
will affect where I go when we hold when
we hold hands and do our shower hump or
Chuck no not a shower I'd really rather
not I just realized that some of the
crates are not in the same place as they
were yesterday
it looks like someone is search through
them did someone enter the bunker while
I was sleeping
could they still be here if so why are
they so quiet are they hiding for me I
myself with a steel pipe and tell them
to show themselves is this me Chagas
album whoa
nothing all right then
god damn it's creepy this is seriously
creepy like honest-to-goodness
he's got good creep factor to it oh but
limit month so this has changed round 2
huh what else has changed huh
another note for myself of course I
didn't get an answer therefore I went
ahead and search through the bunker
again there are not that many places
where a person could be hiding in here
but I couldn't find anyone is it
possible they were leaving the bunker
just when I woke up
what about two douches if they give nope
I said no you go to hell on dude I since
I couldn't find anyone I've decided away
near the answers for their return on
with my steel pipe I'm now sitting on a
country floor battery put the last
remaining fuse in the slot for the
answers to switch on the light but I
didn't do that
No leave that door closed so I'm gonna
do what it tells me to do because who's
in there yeah I thought got a key this
is key to the main door sharp scratching
the chalkboard on my ear I've graduated
shock board I'm off face to stop it
[Applause]
you ain't that scary just because I
screamed like a little girl doesn't mean
you're scary
I waited for like three hours near the
entrances nothing is a bonala here with
the sound of rain while I was waiting I
started to wonder what they were doing
here were they looking for something
there's a value in here
now get up in the bunker stop screaming
we all got problems oh you and your yeah
nothing there's nothing of value in here
just empty crates and barrels shut up
there's no key either yeah I guess
there's nothing to do but wait until
they return I hope they're not criminals
stealing stuff from my bunker how dare
they what if they are hiding something
in here and now they have picked it up
they won't come back
what what that's why you're worried if
they're not going never mind George
Walker is an idiot and he's probably in
here haunting me for the rest of my days
I'm the scary one here I'm sitting on
the floor near the entrance again I've
inspected the main door but there's no
way I'll be ever be able to open to
myself without the key my head I'm going
through the options that I have
unfortunately there are not that many in
fact there's only two if someone opens
the door from the outside I'll die of
thirst in here or stop being so what Oh
was this door here before I don't
remember there being a door back here I
don't think there was let's plate yeah
you wouldn't be that big of a douche you
are exactly that big of a douche how
dare you how dare
okay they're ever gonna be anything in
these drawers is there any point for me
to open these things I don't know I've
spent half an hour pounding on the front
door with my steel pipe maybe someone
heard me I've managed to stay calm so
far I hope I'll be able to keep this up
I have only a little water and food left
and none of the water taps are working
did I just hear someone whisper my name
did you hear a markiplier scream it from
down the hall calling you an idiot
George George George of the jungle watch
out for the tree if you stare into the
shadows for too long your mind will
start playing tricks on you this is
exactly what happened to me now I see
moving through the shadows I need to get
some sleep I will leave the door door
open just in case they come back
even if it seems can't be worse than
dying down here that does not sound like
a good idea I know many good ideas I've
had many bad ones as a pretty bad one
okay I'll keep doke
I'm gonna go take a nap again and I'll
leave the door open cuz I'm smart okay
that's it I'm so tired
it's good idea
okay what's happening Oh big snoring
again god this guy's snores like a
friggin monster
but someone dragged in a steel pipe
George George George is that you George
please don't kill me in my snow gun
No
oh no stop it stop it so tense good God
nothing is really happening yet besides
that one red eye scare I guess I didn't
sleep while I was awakened by the sound
of something having being moved it
sounded as if a shelf or heavy rock was
pulled over concrete I ran out to the
dorm room as soon as I was outside the
noise was gone again well that's good
it's check he's got clothes again maybe
some some new in there
I don't know God face a day it's like a
man
oh hello why is there a wall here there
was no wall here yesterday it's not
possible but this is solid kontrick what
oh you're right there is a wall there
whose didgeridoo indeed redo me you did
you redo yourself what is going on here
the land of the hole bunkers change
overnight the kid needs to be downstairs
but it's now to the left of the entrance
all the loopholes are gone now the rest
of us man what's going on are you me I'm
still not sure if you're me or I'm you
who's who
why anyone is anywhere so almost as if
they died nine days nah Freud Nick hi
that's a damp box you thrown could have
been dangerous good it took my head
clean up that is actually nothing why
does take maestro [ __ ] know like that
do you
your new chalkboard go yeah you would
ever take your chalkboard go join
didgeridoo man over in the kitchen area
all right that's nothing there this game
is making me paranoid I actually think
that there's something there one that
probably isn't Rama
[Music]
you all read that right we're gonna get
out of here
puns Mitch purse oh you and your yapping
again that not tell you yeah problem
main door is where I used to be but of
course it's like know if it even fall
hallway
air smells stale my heart racing how's
the fennel act still work fennel ACK I
can't talk I am the kind of stress is
very tense game nothing has happened and
I'm like stop doing things I don't want
to do hey buddy whoa what the hell this
is different stop it was a scratching
dot wants me I'm into uh I'm still here
I feel a little better my hands are
shaking I have to get out of here now
I've tried to loosen the screws on the
front door with my bare hands now I'm
bleeding in my hands raw I turned hop it
when I heard something whisper my name
from behind me there was known there was
that a face is that really a face on the
got me boots
was that a got me into a face that's got
me a new taste some German dude chappies
got his later hosing bunched up a bit
too tight around here smashing his face
in the signs I'm pretty sure those are
the German equivalent of motivational
posters you know good work don't you be
lazy that's German for you I would know
I'm half it half of it I'm not alone in
here I never was I hear the disturbing
sounds whispering in the dark the voices
are getting louder now I sweat heavily I
should drink more but there's no water
left I gasp or everybody feeling okay
whatever just taking your writings
you better give me back laughs buzzes
you dick you dick ain't gonna be falling
for your trousers back here on the
shower get out my face
ah let's cover me I can't crouch strobe
who's there is anybody there
let that German guy yeah what does that
say boss me
neither do I believe in God nor do I
believe in ghosts but I swear when I
first picked her I saw a face hey I saw
that too am i you I really don't know if
I'm you either way okay
come on bring it on bring it off please
bring it off no I didn't think so
nine end is no project you don't
fraternize with coworkers
I will you're actually a thing we don't
you really think are you just a thing
you thing I smelly smell it smells
smelly shut up time for a nap because
I'm such a badass I'll just to go to
sleep right after a zombie appeared in
front me oh this is how I'm gonna sleep
tonight oh why can't I actually see that
I don't want to see that no that's bad
get that out of here you get the few out
of here close your eyes oh you don't
[Music]
I'm in my pocket move my head but I'm in
my bed I wish I were home instead your
stop laughing at me you laugh again shut
up you're laughing you're screaming I
don't know what emotion to feel right
now feel something on my pants
no not that
my foots walled up or something in my
home something is in my covers back
don't tell me that was the end okay good
I was about to say I was like if that's
how the game ended like ooh a face got
wait a minute what though all right
whatever
I fell asleep again hey my dreams saw
myself sitting in room the walls walls
removing the room was getting smaller
and smaller I woke up I ran out of water
and food I hear someone screaming again
if this is me I'm getting a great early
what is happening no you take that to
the shower have a shower hump dump with
your boyfriend get out of here and I am
not that I have not that and you've done
yet
you are you done good you cleaned up
your own mess at least okay oh it
changed again good how good for you the
main door is gone it was always right
here but now it's gone why is this
happening
am I being punished for something at
least chalkboard man is still here I'm
just waiting for a big German fellow
with a gigantic must ask to come
barreling out with his later hosing in a
heart for some reason my imagination and
then he serenades me
handles jams okay who did what now
handle still jammed I got a key awhile
ago I don't know what the key actually
goes to goes to though yeah unless
you're actually something I ain't gonna
stop okay I'm gonna stop no IOT's
nothing
yeah with nothing I hope my battery
doesn't last out or you know you know
what I mean I stumbled around Amos leave
those ugly pictures now there are more
of them are they trying to tell me
something I do not understand ugly
pictures we need pictures what ugly
pictures you mean the gusty dooms I'm
mad oh there's a face good God I saw
that out of the corner of my eye I was
like they're not registering for like
two seconds and then Allison the face
okay
wait was that another face that wasn't
no my god where are these faces coming
from not really faces more like heads am
I just gonna look up and then suddenly a
head am I gonna look in the mirror and
suddenly I have a head what's wrong with
you
Hale that is so gross stop what
huh let's say okay all right thank you
sir for all your contributions to
society
that's crumbly there's an ugly statue
like thing in one of the rooms who was
not here yesterday some important
looking country another person that's
you holding the key key the main door
man goes gone whispered come sumir join
me do you know German is that how this
goes is that reason why they're all
targeting you because I actually don't
know German hi hi how you doing
hey how you doing they're doing good
how's your mother how's your family
good good here oh how you don't like you
I don't like to smell you I don't like
the look either but we all live with our
shortfalls that can blast houses can
throw brick rocks I'll be doing that
don't be doing that just don't be doing
that oh there's no back door here well I
guess that was the whole point of coming
in here was just get startled by that
face but if I wanted to get startled by
the faces that I have vowed just look in
the mirror itself burn all right cool
anybody in the office down I mean now
there are faces on the walls got normal
the key opened a lock of what Thunder
what I'm pretty sure this could kill me
is this the only way out of here is a
better dying of thirst of all the ways
to go I guess if you had a preference of
being torn apart by zombies arms and
being driven mad and morphine I don't
know no I don't recommend suicide to
anybody that's why this isn't like
totally the inappropriate time to bring
this up but a lot of people you know
they send me messages about how my
videos help them out and they you know
they're able to you know fine you know
find joy in their lives and I'm really
happy that my videos can bring those to
them so I'm glad that I can really help
I really am sincerely glad that I can
help right now I'm in the middle of
something so maybe that's another topic
for another day I'm not tired yet why am
I not tired I didn't find a thing of
morphine what are you talking about I've
been through the whole damn thing
there was nowhere else to go was there
was a medicine cabinet was talking about
a note in that room where room wasn't
talking about a note who's in here right
he opened the locked where the hell is a
lock thing oh wait a minute I know I saw
it it was on the ground before but I
didn't think anything of it it was um I
might have been over a year I might have
been over there I'm not exactly sure a
hundred percent where it wasn't the hell
did you go ah come on somebody open the
door
get on the floor everybody do the deines
okay was back this way hello hey there
oh good on you let's go grab a drink
later if you're not too uh busy back
here I know I saw one earlier it was
just like a chest with a key on it I saw
it where the hell was it am I just
reliving someone else's nightmare
I'm not even original enough to get my
own nightmare I have to copy someone
else's what the hell there's something
oh I felt a rumbly I think it was just
like something over here in Los Angeles
town wait no no no no come on the hell
was it I have no idea where it was I
just remember that I saw it okay maybe I
didn't saw it oh ah
the statue is showing me away no not
away the way I can finally leave this
place but what did it mean when it said
join me I guess I'll find out I'm ready
so okay here's my guess everyone is
repeating the same nightmare and they
are all the statues Oh what the floor is
one of the rooms is unfinished we will
dig a hole there and then force the
[ __ ] to sit in it and fill it up with
concrete she screamed like a little girl
we had to break her legs to beg her sit
still what she swallowed liquid concrete
she became silent
then the Sol's are those who died in
this concrete grave shall never leave
and never find peace instead they shall
become a part of this place their soul
shall be a martyr
their twisted minds the architect you
name its wall I'm gonna destroy you wall
I will destroy you what am I looking at
well okay oh sure I'm tired now all of a
sudden I guess maybe I'll go to bed that
seems like a good idea
I'm practically dying of thirst I'll go
to sleep but not good someone want me to
join them some lady wants to take a
concrete bath with me that doesn't sound
like a pleasant experience but hey I'm
open to anything I'll experiment a bit
what do you want from me
oh oh I can actually move oh I'm not in
bed oh oh oh no oh this is squish all
over again except this time I'm not
wearing an oculus rift don't you do that
you bastard hi this is one of the worst
possible ways to die worst ever like you
just see it coming and you know there's
nothing you can do for it and you try to
stop it it's so crazy to you anyways
stop it I don't want to go like this
again
where was that morphine thing good
please no no let's get a concert all
right fine
try to be brave about this what huh
no you're such a dick this is a [ __ ] ass
you gotta stuff me into the tiniest
corner you're not even gonna squish me
hey yeah you're just gonna keep me
trapped there you big douche I'm ready
for you please the power of my double
finger defense will save me from any
danger they have the strength of ten
thousand men and I'm dead Oh they've
gone limp oh no they've gone limp
they're dangling now
oh they're sad oh I'm not dead what what
but I just spit all over myself but I'm
not dead at the wit I thought that was
like the end or something okay
is everything back to normal now I just
had one crazy dream dosimeters No
well alright then so I guess I'll just
take another lap around the complex see
what things are in store for me
maybe that lady wants to take a concrete
shower humph dump with me know what I
mean that really would suck like suck
doesn't even begin to describe how that
would be like that's just like Earth so
where was that where was that thing I
said I'm spinning a lot but I don't mean
to okay this is the original layout from
the beginning of the game but why oh no
that was there wait a minute
hello aren't you in this rumor oh man
everything's all topsy-turvy I don't
know where anything is anymore cuz this
is your original layout and I didn't
exactly have an idea what I was doing
back then so so where are the heads my
good friend buddy you know stretch limbo
and ding dong and flinger Donna I got I
got this sense of like hesitant and
reluctant apprehensive hope that it's
over but I know in the back of my head
cuz I play these other games that I'm
not gonna get out of here I'm not gonna
escape this this is where I die hello
oh my goodness take the key and run you
don't have to tell me twice where's the
damn gate I'll run I won't run I'm not
even gonna try to hesitate I am running
this is me this is me running I have no
shift button so this movie
don't kill me bro I'm almost there bro I
[Music]
did it I escaped Oh
or did I I did I did I I think sir is
there a way to not escape like if you
get if you stay around there too long
and you get caught so what happens I
have no idea that was really really
really good that was a good or game that
was really fantastic because here's the
one principle that I always taught about
horror games number one it's got a half
atmosphere and that had it in droves I
was creeped out when nothing was
happening I was startled at my own
shadow that was [ __ ] what beautiful I
loved it so anyway you can play it
yourself links in the description below
let me know what you think in the
comments leave a like if you enjoyed
this video and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]